okay I'm game going with sophie de Massa
from Germany's plenty form okay okay
that son I go for the Sicilian and he's
playing the usual spoilsport gc3 okay
maybe I got some interesting play going
with with g6 okay at least this is not
not a dry and boring position
yeah he really insisted on on keeping
the stupid extra pawn on d5 okay yeah of
course all this is some this is some
playable playable for white this was my
DM to transfer this night to the sort of
locating square d 6 the bishop f6 are
always nice tree protect c7 the seventh
one can of course be a problem here yeah
night queen to d3 maybe intending 95
this is something I need to look out for
but my attention wants to to simply m
swap this um this bishop and now just
play on here so questionable if white
can do something here think Scott needs
to porn but no no special play or
something yeah of course it do that
this configuration of bishop f6 47s as
always so it's very nicely protected
here and just stop the H pawn um and
it's hard to tell what white could could
try to to further improve this position
not not sure what this is my beam of
course some black gums also not in a
position to to make any great plans here
the only only idea could be too well to
regain this porn under under favourable
circumstance the center then maybe
blanks Bishop is somewhat better than
whites but it's a very theoretical point
as some most likely this pawn won't
won't drop yeah maybe I can arrest the
bishop somewhat
so it's all in all a very draw position
Roxy 3m maybe beef I proxy 3m this is
some this is a bit inconvenient don't
want to have that that happening maybe
maybe the screen booth
also taking the form
k is just attacking the rook
but now the forcer hanging rope d3i go a
four and then d5 should be a problem
shouldn't shouldn't it be problem I just
I can just grab the five now
d force also not sure not pretty yeah
but this is this interesting now what
should I do now taking on d4 maybe I'm
only gives a Jewish endgame maybe I
maybe look at five maybe this is some
giving better better winning ideas now
checking on the wait wait wait wait
notes not so quickly maybe I had just
just grab this here I cannot take with
the bishop f2 is hanging and if he takes
with the Queen I've got them at least
Queen a two maybe I've got some other
idea but can grab the corner yeah
yeah strange move killing the bishop
here this Bishop looks um somewhat
technically vulnerable interesting
Bishop g4 then what rookie 223
time warning
cool
okay I don't see okay this I think now I
can just I can just take on f3 enter
transpose to this end game here threat
now Bishop b2 to push the porn home so I
think he needs to really play this one
exactly and now it's a it's a dead rope
here and I still have half the deep pawn
so this must be a win it's essentially
like opponent game king of porn and game
with an extra porn because this
configuration canceled each other out so
it's just just the extra porn and effect
yep white for things on time yeah this
soap from was a rather quick win from
nothing position surprisingly yeah in
this kind of position of course it's I
think it's just just evil about terminal
plate this Sun get some strange museum
now was quickly getting getting pawns
and play on this King and this a pawn of
course this was was rather easy so I'd
seen this idea two or three moves ago so
was easy now cannot cannot do anything
here to prevent this yeah yeah nice one
thing